[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
burn it all down until it's a
huge Heap
smoldering ashes [__] Twitter
I don't know is that what we're going
with this morning I don't know if you've
seen the news
Zuckerberg's meta threads
is owning Elon zass this morning
apparently there's a gazillions of new
users using uh meta's threads I have
opened account on metas threads
um
you know
listen
is it gonna be less Nazi for the time
being than Twitter maybe
um is it is it gonna be an echo chamber
most definitely 100 percent it's social
media what else is it gonna be all right
I mean you know I'm not I'm not like
super excited about having another
[__] social media app to tell you
honest truth
um it is tied to Instagram
so if you got an Instagram account it's
very easy to open up a threads account
you just use your Instagram account
it's really easy you just push a few
buttons bingo bango bongo and you're in
so uh go get on the threads train
now with this is probably
the social media app
that is has the most potential
to replace Twitter oh by the way I'm
back did you did you notice that
I'm back I'm back from a vacation
um and I didn't take a day of rest
yesterday to not drink you know that I
am
oh boy I think I
I drank way too much over the holiday
and probably I got high too many times
but that's just how it goes right it was
a holiday I was on vacation what do you
want from me and really honestly I
didn't watch the news at all the only
thing I know is that there's was cocaine
in the white house that's the only
that's it that's the only piece of news
I got to commentate on today so you're
going to hear me talk about cocaine in
the white house for the next two hours
and and and that Zuckerberg wins the
cage match right
they were supposed to fight
right
Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk are gonna
fight come on man are you [__]
[__] me
Zuckerberg throws the first punch
now will it destroy Twitter no
I mean it's not gonna destroy Twitter is
still gonna be full of a bunch of Nazis
that you can go over there and [__] with
all the time anytime you want
they're going to be over there right for
the picking you know a lot of people
block a lot of these [__] right
they block them mute them whatever I go
at them
I don't know how many times in the last
few weeks
I've quote treated Laura Loomer and
[__] lunatic
now they're gonna all make their way
over to threads
um to be fair though they're already
bitching the right-wing Nazis are
already bitching that we're being
censored this isn't free speech yeah
dummy there's terms and services you
[__] idiot it isn't free speech on a
social media app that's not a thing stop
saying that stupid [__] that's not your
freedom of speech it's not
that's why this is all so stupid why he
spent this much money to destroy Twitter
because he thinks social media is free
speech and all his stupid bone-headed
followers think social media is Free
Speech it's not you [__] idiots
that's not what free speech is
I know you want to type in your hatred
in your bigotry without any consequence
or repercussion on an app I get it I get
how [__] how [__] horny it makes
you
to say racist bigoted [__] and type it
out
on your favorite on your favorite app
but that's not free speech that's not
it's just not I know you think it is and
it feels like it is at first glance it
feels like oh well if you're trying to
prevent me from saying something online
then you're fringing on my freedom to to
say whatever I want no you're not no
they're not go say it where you can say
it you [__] idiot
just because Twitter allows you to say
something doesn't mean you should say it
and just because another social media
platform doesn't allow you to say it
doesn't mean they're they're infringing
on your freedom of speech
you can go stand on a corner with a
cardboard sign you [__] idiot do it
the old-fashioned way oh but the
internet Tony but the internet yeah but
you don't own these websites you don't
own these apps
go open your own [__] app that's what
that's what Grandpa Poopypants had to do
to type in his [__] crazy ass rants
he had he had to [__] defraud a bunch
of people defraud a bunch of his
supporters
you know in this SPAC deal people are
going to go to prison over this back
deal so that he can [__] type out his
craziness
that's what he did no one would let him
on their their [__] app or their
website so he went and opened his own
that's freedom speech okay
and just understand how it works
understand how it works
uh Texas Paul actually is the one who uh
sent me a thing this morning he probably
is like yeah Tony's probably still dung
over and drunk from his long weekend I
don't know maybe I'll ask him on Tuesday
he messaged me he said hey man did you
get on threads people are trying to copy
you over there or something there's like
a I don't know there's a spoof account
or some [__] I'm like God what the what
the [__] is threads I had no idea I had
no idea until about uh two hours ago
what this [__] threads thing was no
clue I'm telling you I've been out out
of it out of pocket I didn't watch the
news at all none of it
if I was off man
when I take a vacation
I take a vacation that's what I do
and again I may have drank a few Bud
Light queer beers on Monday and I got
high a couple times so you know
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do but I'm glad
you're here I don't know if the whole
audience is here today it's probably a
little sparse because they're like where
the [__] is Tony right
um oh
Mark asked what is this threads
So Meta Facebook right you know what I'm
talking about Zuckerberg he opened up a
new app to compete with Twitter and it's
got I don't know it's got like 30
million followers or is it more than
that I don't know I don't know how many
followers it got like 10 million in the
first couple hours
when they open this this thing up and it
opened up almost a day before it was
supposed to or some [__]
now um kind of reminds me I'm not gonna
lie it kind of reminds me of original
Facebook
I'm not gonna lie your story on Facebook
or whatever and your news feed that's
what it reminds me of it's what it looks
like kind of right like it's just like
oh we're just gonna do the old Facebook
thing because Facebook's so [__] up
right and then I you know I I'm
broadcasting here on Facebook you can
watch us on Facebook and I'm on Facebook
I'm on everywhere just go to the Tony
Michaels and I'm there
but it reminds me of old Facebook like
the original the OG Facebook that's what
that's what it kind of reminds me of
this threads but just go to your your
app store just go to your App Store look
up threads it's by meta which is
Facebook's parent company
and you can you can use your Instagram
account to open the threads account like
if you got an Instagram account you want
to use the same handle and [__] you just
click same same same bam you're good
you're in you're in like Flynn and start
messaging follow me follow everyone else
and just start going just start pounding
away at this these right wing idiots now
I I will say
that
um
I don't I don't know how this is gonna
go you guys know we use Twitter a lot
when we're searching for like videos and
stuff like that to show you guys it's an
easy platform as a timeline and an
archive just to show you what we're
showing here on the show just share
stuff [__] around you know what I mean
it's kind of easy that's what I like
about Twitter
it's what I've always liked about
Twitter is it's easy to share this [__]
you don't have to go searching for it
it's right there now in recent months
obviously it's gone to [__] hell in a
hand basket
with [__] Elmo at the helm
but maybe that's gonna change with
threads two ways it could change number
one threads could be a very stiff
competition for the traffic right which
means money I don't know if Elon
understands this
hey could someone get me Elon on the
phone I want to talk to him look listen
Elon man if all your traffic moves like
and what I mean by traffic is non-bot
non-nazi traffic moves
from Twitter to threads you're you're
you're gonna lose your high highway
visibility okay think of think of uh
Twitter's like a highway right and it's
got Billboards all over the place you've
been in parts of the country Missouri's
got a shitload of billboards it's it's
[__] it's just gross how many
Billboards we have here in Missouri
it is kind of gross
I mean it hides all the [__]
landscape makes the thing it just looks
like a goddamn
big advertisement down the highway and
whether it's the interstate or it's uh
State highways whatever it is
it said have you ever driven down
Highway 70 I-70 you know what I'm
talking about Interstate 70 from St
Louis Kansas City you know what I'm
talking about just looks like [__] all
the Billboards but that's that think
about that highway is Twitter right or
threads whichever and they're selling
space on these Billboards right
well Elon elon's highway just got shut
down
are
more than anything there's no traffic on
it so who the [__] would buy a billboard
on on a highway where no one's driving
right think about it that way
so threads is going to change a couple
different things here threads is going
to change
um the the the the the the monetary
model of Twitter because now elon's
gonna go out [__] now I gotta
the money I was making it's gone and
this investors are going to make him
change so
my guess is is that Elon is really going
to have to do a lot of readjusting and
what he really should do is quit Elon
you should [__] quit man just [__]
quit just quit go back to being some
[__] [__] that you go on 100
podcasts a week to talk about how
[__] genius you are and say stupid
word salad to make you sound like you
think you know [__] okay go back to
doing that
go back to doing that and let someone
who [__] understands Twitter and
social media and understands this [__]
to run it and make it profitable so
maybe that it can survive maybe just
maybe I don't know
I mean I'm I'm I don't give a [__] if
Twitter dies
I don't give a [__] [__] that Bird app
but here's the thing is if if it can be
saved
let's save it why not but he's not gonna
do that
his investors might but he's not going
to he's a ding-a-ling
have you ever seen this guy in an
interview have you ever watched him talk
about Twitter he's such a [__] idiot
this is the guy who thinks Twitter's
Free Speech the only the only [__]
person Twitter is free speech for listen
to me when I tell you this the only
person
that Twitter is free speech for is Elon
that's it
until his investors tell him no and then
he's not anymore then it's not his
because he doesn't really own Twitter
you know that right
he doesn't own Twitter it's mortgaged
and I you got a mortgage on your house
right
you tried paying that not paying that
[__] for three or four months
see who owns that [__] see who owns
your house just don't try not paying
your mortgage I don't five six seven
months
see who owns your house
Elon doesn't own Twitter
investors on Twitter
Elon just borrowed money
from the Saudi mob
to look like he owns Twitter
but this is this is the the crossroads
right
of social media now why is this
important in the in in the grand scheme
of politics
an hour and our daily lives here in
America is very [__] important
it's very important
because they're they're gonna try to use
social media to steal the election
and by they I mean manga in Russia
that's right [__] it I don't give a [__]
even if I can call me conspiracy
theorist or whatever you want but manga
and Russia are going to try to use
social media
steal the election they've aren't
they've been trying they've been doing
it for [__] two years now three years
now oh I didn't lose I'm such a little
[__] oh I'm such a sore [__] loser
I didn't lose I won
spreading this misinformation all this
[__] around social media and then as
soon as Elon owns Twitter they spread
more misinformation about covid like
they're gonna rehash covet as if this
country wants to rehash covet have you
noticed that the right wing is just
incessant on [__] rehashing 2020.
importantly March April and May of 2020.
Jesus [__] Christ man
I mean yeah I understand you know
there's a lot of mistakes made sometimes
there was good things done
but Jesus Christ are we really gonna
[__] stand here and make this
election about the past you people are
dumb as dog [__] and ain't no wonder the
Republican Party sucks
right Am I Wrong Jesus Christ Ron
DeSantis can't even get get out of his
little lull that he's in in the polls
when he's up against a [__] an
indicted felon
he's got he's got over 70 counts felony
counts that he's indicted on God knows
how many he's going to be indicted on
soon in Georgia and DC maybe Arizona
possibly [__] Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania I don't know I don't know
how many jurisdictions they're going to
charge him in as far as the federal
prosecutors are concerned
I mean this this this fake State elector
scheme uh man it seems like there could
be plenty of federal charges that come
out of that for Donald Trump and others
but Donald Trump specifically
I mean I I wouldn't I wouldn't doubt
that he's going to have 200 felonies by
the time he wins the nomination because
this is the other stupid [__] I keep
hearing this now I understand that some
people that you like have said this too
listen I know it's early I know it's
early like and you can't really tell
with polls because I don't [__]
listen to them
I just know what's gonna happen
it's very clear it's a cult and if you
know how Cults work you know that he's
gonna be the nominee
I will last night and he was on Twitter
was it last night I think it was last
night last night or yesterday evening I
don't remember
kind of run together I was like you know
what I need to catch up on some [__] and
I went on Twitter and Mario had a space
and it was it was Trump versus DeSantis
oh my God you had said gork in there uh
you had um let's see who else he had a
bunch of DeSantis supporters and you had
DC Drano and some other [__] Trump
supporters it was hilarious oh my God oh
my God they [__] hate each other uh
hating on Lord of Loomer hating on Trump
hating on DeSantis it's fantastic
they're eating each other alive
and you don't even know it a lot of
times like you're not even aware of this
war that is going on on the dark web
and the hidden spots on Twitter and
these other social media places but they
[__] are going at each other
I mean they're really throwing punches
more than uh Zuckerberg's throwing
punches on elon's Twitter today
they're they're gonna they're gonna kill
each other Ron desantis's career is over
his political career is over
now yeah but some people like Tony come
on man you can't call that right now you
can't say them [__] I can't I'll say
whatever I want
Rhonda Santos his career political
career is all but over
what I mean how don't you see it number
one now that people know that he's a
[__] weirdo
now that they know he's a weirdo I'll
give you an example we've used it before
Scott Walker he was the governor of
Wisconsin he he survived a recall right
and he went to Iowa which I I don't know
if you know
geography but like Wisconsin is like
Northern Iowa right like if there's
North Dakota and South Dakota there's
Iowa and Northern Iowa Wisconsin right I
mean and not exactly but it's kind of
the it's the same
anyone from Wisconsin or Iowa out there
don't don't knock me I'm just [__] what
do you want from me
the thing is is that
Scott Walker was the governor of
Wisconsin survived a recall
um its popularity was high in the
Republican Party his buddy Paul Ryan
became the speaker of the house they
were best buds
uh reince priebus you remember reince
priebus you remember this guy he was the
head of the RNC he became Trump's first
Chief of Staff do you remember that I'm
throwing way back [__]
that's right Tony's memory survives
but Scott Walker was supposed to be just
the the president of all president he
was going to be the Republican Savior of
our country the new Ronald Reagan [__]
me
he was going to be the new Ronald Reagan
you remember this
where the [__] is Scott Walker oh yeah
he's a weirdo he's a [__] weirdo
he didn't know how to campaign on a
national scale he couldn't manage it he
didn't know
he didn't understand what what he was
getting into is way out in front of his
skis
and he face planted
he had to get out before Iowa
Ron DeSantis is in the same boat and not
only that the [__] can't stop
saying the word woke it looked stupid
even even to the [__] manga cultist
it looks dumb as dog [__]
he can't stop saying it because the
problem is is not only does not does Ron
DeSantis not know what woke means the
manga cult is really confused about what
woke is like they're really [__]
confused about this stuff
I mean just look at the Bud Light thing
they think they took down the company
called Bud Light
Bud Light is just a label dummy
and as your bush just owns the label
they don't give a [__] if you buy their
other beer or not
I mean Bud Light had a good run
as the great the Great American Beer
they don't even understand the history
behind this [__] like Bud Light and why
their little boycott didn't work in the
first place and it was never gonna work
they don't understand it they don't get
this stuff that's the same way Rhonda
santis doesn't understand a national
campaign
they don't get it they're too blinded by
their [__] hate and their stupid ass
delusion
that they can't they can't they can't
see
what's in front of them and what's in
front of them is Donald Trump is gonna
run away with this
I mean Jesus Christ you have over the
weekend Trump supporters attacking the
California GOP I don't know if you know
this I did track this news
because
I want to track the [__] sandwich eating
the [__] sandwich if you want to know
the uh the honest truth
uh someone pointing out the comments
still up hey you know did I answer what
threads was about I don't know [__] I
might still be hungover anyways what was
I saying oh yes oh yes the California
GOP the California GOP and Maga
supporters are getting into it they're
[__] having a Heyday Trump's pissed
off at them the Trump campaign's pissed
off at them they're all pissed
and the reason why is because the
California GOP is trying to change how
their delegates are handed out to the
nominee
now this could make a difference
probably not it could make a difference
though if someone emerges to get
delegates at State conventions but
listen folks this is all affiliation and
to believe
to believe in the Republican primary
because the Republican primary does not
have super delegates like the Democratic
primary you know that right they don't
have super delegates what is known as
super delegates see the Democratic party
made sure after 1968 they're like look
we're not doing that [__] again
what we're going to do is make sure that
the party chooses who the [__]
nominee is
we're not we're not going to let our
party get destroyed because people don't
can't get their head out of their ass
so the people in the party the members
of the party okay you got it the members
of the party not just someone who's like
I'm a Democrat that's not you're not a
member of the party just saying you're
Democrat just voting Democrat doesn't
mean you're a member of the party nor
are you an elected official of the party
in other words you don't hold any power
over the party
you're just a voter
and maybe that's a wrong way to look at
it but that's the [__] truth
that's the [__] truth and Republicans
wish they had some super delegates in
2016 they really wish the answers were
super delegates now
is he's gonna win
if he gets the delegates and he has
enough delegates on the first ballot to
win that vote he will be the nominee
that's how it works
it doesn't get I don't give a [__] about
what polls there are I don't care about
crowd size I don't give a [__] about
who's got more bumper stickers or Flags
or hats I don't give a [__]
that doesn't matter what matters is how
many delegates are brought to the
convention next summer
and he does not it doesn't matter what
kind of legal trouble he gets in it
doesn't even matter if he's in a jail
cell for crying out loud
he can win
but Ronda santis is on the same
trajectory as Scott Walker
where is Scott Walker show me where he
is
show me what office he holds I mean he's
a board member and a Rhonda Santa's
future looks like you realize that right
Ron DeSantis is gonna [__] just crash
and burn here he'll never be able to
enter Republican politics again because
Trump and Maga is going to destroy him
so what he'll do is he'll go he'll be on
the board the board here and the board
there and the executive board here and
he'll get paid hundreds of millions of
dollars
to control to control companies and
money
that's what he'll do
that's what he'll do and he'll live a
great life being super [__] rich and
the former fascist governor of Florida
[__] piece of [__] you think he lives
in Florida when he retires I don't know
I don't know you thought you thought
when I started off and I'm like look I
didn't look at the [__] news
I had no idea what the hell is going on
in the world and the only thing I heard
over the weekend is that someone found
some cocaine in the White House
is this really that big of a surprise
that there's cocaine in the White House
are we serious about this you're you're
worried about cocaine in the White House
the other thing too I noticed online is
Right Wingers are freaking out about
this Hunter Biden video have you seen
this they are freaking out about Hunter
Biden wiping sweat off his face I'm not
getting you he's on the balcony at the
White House they're watching fireworks
the dude is [__] just they're all
drenched in sweat it's July it's
Washington DC it's hotter than a
[__] so he's wiping sweat off
his face and they're like oh look at him
he he he's twitching twitching he's
liming I I'm like have you ever watched
one clip of Don Jr's triggered are you
kidding me you people are wild man these
[__] right Wingers ooh baby I'm glad
to be back I'm happy to be back with you
here today on this Thursday July 6th did
you have a good Independence Day Let
Freedom Ring uh to do that go ahead and
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
right here on YouTube go ahead and share
the [__] link around you know people
don't know we're back yet I don't know
maybe maybe they do maybe they don't I
don't know they might so share the link
around share the YouTube link around
um
also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels Pond and go follow me on
threads I don't have a Graphic for it
yet go follow me on threads it's the
same at the Tony Michaels
it's the same thing so go download the
app threads it's by meta it's in your
Apple store or your whatever the Android
store whatever the hell kind of phone
you get
I don't know will they have the desktop
version I know Instagram has a desktop
version I don't know if the threads does
or not I hope so Jesus Christ if we
don't [__] [__] them if they don't have
a threads um desktop soon like in the
next week or two [__] that [__]
that's what I say
uh follow us speaking a minute follow us
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
watch it there live
every single weekday I also have a huge
favor to ask on Twitch and we have a lot
of people that have um
linked their Amazon Prime account to
their Twitch account right so here's
what happens if you got an Amazon Prime
account you can link it to your Twitch
account and you get one free
subscription with your Prime account to
Amazon gaming and you can give it to us
on Twitch and we get a couple bucks
every month but you have to re-subscribe
every single month
should go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels to
subscribe with your Amazon Prime account
if you don't have it relinked if you
don't have it linked and you need to
link it up
just go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com you'll find the
directions there it's the fourth link
down it says link Amazon and twitch link
it and it also gives you the directions
on how to resub so make sure to
resubscribe we got we got um oh man
there's probably 70
70 folks out there 70 accounts out there
that need to resubscribe and I know I've
been on for five days so and it is the
first of the month you know it happens
it happens it's cool uh we'll we'll get
it going we'll get it going don't worry
we'll get back on track so make sure to
go to the Tony michaels.com or go to
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels and
make sure that you re-subscribe over
there with your Amazon Prime account if
you're on Twitch yeah someone just
someone just subscribed and Shadow
woman's giving away uh Community Subs
over there so thank you very much for
that everyone and get get to Twitch
get to Twitch I wonder if we're gonna be
able to stream on threads [__] I don't
know who knows God I don't know I hope
so we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
let's see is there a threads what the
hell was this um
[Music]
is it on desktop I don't know
red red shreds let's find it you know I
don't see it I don't see a desktop
version yet
I don't know
maybe maybe they'll get a desktop
version eventually
we're gonna get to and we're gonna get
I'm trying it I'm trying it I promise
you I'm trying to see if there is one I
don't think there is it's just the
mobile app
it's just a moment but it's all the news
this morning that the this this this new
meta app Mark Zuckerberg's new Facebook
app or our Instagram app I think it's
tied to Instagram more and it is
Facebook but it looks like old Facebook
Am I Wrong let's get some comments going
here and wait let's see
let's get some comments going in let's
see if someone uh thinks what they think
about this thing what they think about
this thing
um
does I think it looks like
um old Facebook right like the OG
Facebook
is what it looks like me and then
they're saying it's tied to Instagram
that's how I signed up here's how I
signed up I went to I downloaded the app
and then because I'm logged into the
Instagram on an app on my phone it just
wanted to know if I wanted to like copy
the Instagram
so
boom they did uh thank you Crystal
crystal said she resubbed on Twitch
uh she said that from Facebook so thank
you very much yeah we got a bunch of we
got a bunch of resubs here
so thank you very much uh for resubbing
over on Twitch helps us out a lot here
on the show
why did you guys have a good let's talk
about this do you guys have a good
holiday weekend did you go watch
fireworks
why what the hell is with the YouTube
listen I I know I know um a lot of you
out there are watching on YouTube but I
can't see you what the [__]
nah there's no YouTube comments coming
through
none of them I don't know
I have no idea why that's happening
see you you get hope about the internet
and social media right
with this threads thing news coming and
then boom
boom nothing I can't even I can't get
the the
comments on YouTube there's a few but
not a lot
yeah well see it's uh um the moderators
are saying that it's working but here's
the thing is that it's not pushing
through to my feed
right I can see it on the regular one
but the problem is is I can't bring it
up
yeah [__]
wanna and what a pain in the ass
technology right but that's again that's
why I say this thread thing is going to
change a lot
This Thread thing is not just gonna
change the
um
the downfall Twitter I actually believe
it'll change the upswing at Twitter
right well here's what I mean by that
what I mean by that
is that it will
it will make sure that Elon gets his ass
back on track because his investor is
going to say look you can't you can't do
that
you can't do that
you're gonna have to [__] compete
with this guy so he's gonna have to
compete with threads maybe maybe not
maybe thread shits the bed I don't know
let me go see you because it's a mobile
app so I can't show it to you uh very
easily on the screen here
um but it kind of the the
the logo is kind of like an ant curly
cue right it's kind of weird
now let's see
yeah so there's over 400 people
following me so far and I've had it open
for I don't know a couple hours
so
Hell Boy we'll see what happens
um
a lot of people are worried about the
chat I don't know what's going on with
the chat I don't know
I yeah it's YouTube maybe it's it's
possible YouTube again you're able to
chat in the chat I'm just not able to
see you on my back in because what you
have to understand is I have a broadcast
studio a digital one it's a virtual
broadcast studio that that
it goes out to all the platforms like
Facebook twitch YouTube uh the up wires
YouTube uh Twitter hopefully threads
here soon hey Zuckerberg can't someone
can someone give me Mark Zuckerberg on
the phone I want to make sure we can
broadcast to threads tomorrow
well you know last week Blue Sky was all
the thing there was people message me
why aren't you on Blue Sky why aren't
you on blue sky I'm like Jesus [__]
Christ now blue sky is the uh social
media uh platform that Jack Dorsey the
uh the former CEO of Twitter uh when
when Elon brought bought it uh he opened
one up I'm like what
I don't I know Jesus and I got Mastodon
do I have to have all of these
it's just crazy
I gotta have all these I don't know Gabe
Sanchez is going to be joining us here
in just a second and we're going to ask
him about this threads and about Twitter
see what he thinks
you know he stays up on this [__] more
he probably was watching news a lot more
than I was over the weekend
um
I don't know
I actually I actually took took way off
and what I mean decided to [__] for five
days I mean I did a little bit of
drinking and getting you know a little
high that's it and I'm I'm telling you
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be honest with
you here I'm gonna be transparent here
I'm not gonna lie to you I'm not gonna
mislead you give you uh [__]
information like yeah I was watching the
news the whole time I was totally
watching the news the five days I was
off
no I wasn't seeing two Fireworks shows
no they were pretty good uh one was
really close it was a really good show
and then the the other one was at the
the Missouri state capitol I wouldn't
launched that one
um on the capital line
yeah so so they they uh here's what they
do for the state fireworks and the state
the state does this puts this on and
then they they put a barge out in the
Missouri River right and they shoot the
fireworks off a barge out in the river
so they're they're they're really
they're really um they're really they're
really nice and they and we went to the
to the Capitol now I'm not so excited
about that because you gotta Park and
it's a [__] there's tons of traffic
afterwards in a million [__] people
and it pisses me off
um but we went and walked
um up to the Capitol and we we put our
chairs there and we watched the the
fireworks by the music you know they had
the music going
so I thought that was I thought it was
good you know you gotta watch fireworks
on the fourth of July some people don't
like fireworks some people don't like
the Fourth of July
you know like Independence Day in
general especially when these uh these
fake grits uh really bastardize
patriotism the Fourth of July and and
our country and you know you see these
[__] idiots with their American flags
with Trump written on them like Jesus
Christ
and you're supposed to be a patriot and
you're bitching you know what's crazy is
the [__] who has American flag
that has Trump written on it or his face
under some [__] right
that's the same some [__] that's gonna
[__] and moan when someone's burning a
flag in protest same [__]
big stuff over on Twitch says in
Missouri Tony yes
or you call it Missouri misery Missouri
[Music]
Mizzou is all kinds of words for it the
show me state
is where I'm from
the show me state
I I'm originally from um like
like Missouri hard Missouri the Lake of
the Ozarks you know where the Netflix
series Ozarks
is shot I go set that's where I'm
originally from I grew up about 10
minutes
from where that is set
I grew up on a farm
close to the Lake of the Ozarks so like
you know
I I've seen my share of meth heads and
white trash and it's funny because when
you drive down the highway to get to uh
and I've done a video on Tick Tock about
this
um when you drive down to the Lake of
the Ozark there's uh right outside my
hometown as you're driving along Highway
54 it's the main Corridor into the lake
area on the St Louis side
um there's a big huge Confederate flag
now when I was a kid no one [__] flew
the confeder I mean as few people right
would have the Confederate flag like in
the rumors [__] you know or like they
like the Dukes of Hazard or Alabama
right they had the Confederate flag on
[__] the Battle Flag but no one no one
gave a [__] about the Battle Flag
in that part of Missouri technically in
Missouri the southern part of Missouri
was the union the northern part
was with the South
it's kind of weird because Missouri's
backwards right all the Farmland is
north of the Missouri River
all the Farmland you got it Farms
everything south of the Missouri River
just [__] Hills and and just Rocky
Forest can't grow [__] you can't grow
any cotton in southern Missouri if
you've ever been to like Branson or
Springfield or the Lake of the Ozarks
you know God damn that's the worst place
in the world to grow crops
north of the rivers where you grow all
the crops right
so that's where the the slaves were in
Missouri that's where the slave owners
were
that's where the plantations the Farms
it was the southern people the people in
the Hills that were the that were the
outcasts they were the ones that were at
the union
they were the ones that were Progressive
they're the ones that didn't want slave
[__] they were broken poor themselves
this is kind of weird when you drive to
Lake the Ozarks right and there's this
big battle flag and it's huge they I I'm
not [__] you it's a [__] huge
pole and it's just out out by the
highway like literally intentionally out
by the highway and they gotta what the
[__] they got a fence around it right
they got a fence around this this flank
pole there's [__] cameras on it
there's lights they got a security
system on this flagpole and the reason
why is because someone's likely to cut
that some [__] off because you know
[__] the Confederates you [__] lost
speaking of losers I don't know who the
hell we got in the um in the green room
here but um sure does look like a
character I was expecting Gabe Sanchez
to show up at some point but um we got a
guest here
um how can I help you sir Tony Tony it's
me oh it's Gabe it's been 84 long years
we've been off the air for so did you
grow a beard over the holiday
I
I let myself go really I really let
myself go [__] God damn so um how did
you let yourself go over the um the
holiday what what what did you uh
partner I didn't have anyone checking in
on me every day I didn't check in on you
I mean we talked a few times yeah I was
trying to keep traveling uh it was I was
left to my own demise oh [__] you were
alone the inmates were the inmate was
running the Asylum oh okay and uh it
looks like it looks like it got crazy
over there well it got a little a little
a little bit Loco over here but yeah I
feel like uh I was able to to have a
good time while I was all alone you know
with my thoughts just your thoughts huh
just just you know I didn't actually
think you could grow a beard like that
to be quiet I didn't either but if you
put enough stress on the body right
um you can really you can really produce
a lot of gray hair so long very quickly
uh just the idea of which app I was
gonna stay on if it was going to be
threads or it was gonna be Twitter or
was it gonna be Mastodon or it's gonna
be counter social or it was going to be
yeah Blue Sky yeah I have no idea no
idea that was the thing this morning uh
because I told the audience earlier that
Texas poll he messaged me and he's like
hey man are you on thread yet I'm like
the [__] is threads I have no idea where
have you been I I drunk I was drunk huh
I see that and I got stoned a lot over
the weekend that's just what I did what
the [__] do you think I was gonna do
when I was off and not doing that I mean
I would do it with the show don't get me
wrong I would still get stoned and drunk
I mean hell I'm still a little hung over
today so what are you gonna do but so I
woke up this morning and it was only a
couple hours ago literally when I woke
up and I was like what's this threads
thing and I was like oh it's meta and it
was like blowing up it's all the rage so
yeah you were over there when did you
open your account when did you open your
account like almost immediately were you
the first 10 million were you uh yeah
dude that was like the first my number
is
yeah
let's see gotta go over to Instagram to
get my number do you actually get a
number yeah you get a number when you
first join and obviously there's gonna
be
yeah so obviously you're going to be
there's a group of people that were on
there before which is like celebrities
and politicians and things like that
that were on there before anyone really
joined because
stuff I think they gave me my account
because someone was trying to open up
spoof accounts
so what they do is everyone technically
has an account
[Music]
I have an Instagram right I have an
Instagram account then you technically
have a threads account it's just on hold
until you activate it and until that
point
you have a bunch of people who can
request to follow you so I had that when
I joined there was a handful of people
that oh is that why I had to confirm all
the [__] exactly
like several hundred of them but now
that you've joined you don't have to go
through that process anymore oh okay so
that's wondering I'm like [__] am I
gonna have to confirm every single one
of these yeah it's just that your
account was on hold and until you
activate it everyone's follow was just
out there in this kind of um
uh
I don't know I guess you would call like
a
so what do you what I don't know it's
like a middle ground where it basically
doesn't exist yet so what what do you
think of the you know what reminds me of
and I was telling the audience this
earlier yeah it reminds me of OG
Facebook like it literally it just looks
like it looks like Facebook right am I
right Am I Wrong OG Facebook yeah like
it just the [__]
thread it's just a thread with
I don't know I I'm not sure about that
you Boomer look how long have you had a
[__] Facebook account you know you're
not even on Facebook I was uh I look
also I just looked at my number I was
the first 472
000 people that joined damn so you were
the first half million yeah yeah what
can I say
you're like one of the first because you
know that you know they had like at
least 200 000 accounts stacked yeah
there's probably a fair amount of people
celebrities and Brands uh I mean the
Brand's alone that are willing to think
they activated those accounts without
letting those Brands know no no no
they've been working with those Brands
to get them ready to go so they want
they wanted to have a nice uh a nice
they wanted to have the ability to have
an inside look right there's probably a
press embargo that was put on because
technically threads are supposed to open
up today and they launched it early last
night
when I Got a notification that said are
you eating your beard there how does it
taste is it I feel like I'm [__] Dan
Aykroyd from Trading Places
um anyway
wow [__] but but yeah there are some
moments where the hair gets in my mouth
that's fine it's fine totally totally
committed to the big committed to the
beginning and if you're listening to
this audio version you gotta come look
at this stupid bastard with his [__]
I feel like Forrest Gump I just kept
already done it looked running why
didn't you get a Bubba Gump Shrimp um
hat uh totally I I totally wanna wish I
wish I wish I would have seen it you
don't have a bubble gum shrimp and I
figured he did nope nope closet back
there story no it's not true story never
been to a bubble gum shrimp really I've
been to once I've been once and it's a
it's a [__] gimmick I mean it's good
I saw one in uh Times Square right and
that was it I never I never thought that
I had to go there I would also I would
also look at uh when I was in Times
Square there were a bunch of kids that
were on a field trip right probably some
surrounding Metro City or something like
that that came into that came into New
York or from out of state or something
and they were going straight into bubble
gum shrim and I was like no don't do
that I was like there's all these other
places you could go so that could
probably be more accommodating and
better food but it wasn't that bad it
wasn't that bad I mean it was expensive
for the experience yeah well I think we
went I think
um I think there's one in Daytona Beach
I think that sounds like a prime spot
yeah Daytona Beach I think that's where
um we went to Bubba Gump Shrimp Company
at was a Daytona Beach right and you
know they when they come to the table
they talk about they give you Forrest
Gump you know quotes and you know [__]
about the movie and stuff like that so
that's what you're paying for right yeah
all right it's all right it's it's okay
but it's not them but in terms of uh in
terms of threads back to threads yeah
well trending in in the chat thread here
Jerry Garcia Sanchez is uh is trending
in the uh that is actually my uncle hey
let me ask you real quick before you get
back to threads can you see the YouTube
chat on your end on stream yard I can't
see it I can see people chat and see
some
I hope you had a nice break I can see
the mods but I can't see anyone else
that's all I can see this oh yeah I can
only see Facebook
see it's not just mine it's it's you
something's going on with YouTube
they're not they're not only seeing the
mods yeah we can see Facebook we can see
twitch but we can't if if you're trying
to if you're trying to message us we
can't see it through our end yeah yeah
and and I can't bring it up so I
apologize for that but anyways so back
to threads because I really what do you
think because here's the thing
as I was getting on there this morning
I'm looking at it and I'm trying to look
at the news and I'm trying to figure out
what the hell threads is and why it's
relevant and I figured it out I was like
wow this is really going to change the
landscape and it's not just going to
change like the the um
Twitter in the way of that a bunch of
people are going to get off the platform
it's going to change it to where the
investors mainly but Elon Shirley has to
really question his leadership there
like dude you're gonna have to bail on
this thing I have a theory about what's
happening on Twitter right now I've got
a a post that I was going to do before I
got on the show but I wasn't able to I
was was not able to put it up basically
I don't know if other people uh who are
listening or yourself if you've noticed
that there are more of these like I'll
call them timeline cleanser accounts
they're the like cute cute puppies cute
cat look at this
right so this is my theory
I looked at
the accounts and I was like this is a
little bit weird there's a lot of these
in my feed right now I don't even follow
this account and I I can't remember the
last time if I've ever actually engaged
liked or commented uh if at all with
these accounts
so I went into the following and I said
well who are they following and notice
they following 10 people right and I've
seen this across other people or other
other spots
um
on Twitter as well
they're following 10 people one is Elon
Musk another one is Linda whatever or
whatever the [__] her name is um
the CEO the new CEO
um the next one I notice are a couple
people who are on the product or on the
design team at Twitter so so these like
bot accounts you think oh and and and
also and also
tell me why
an account that is dedicated
to having cute animals
cleansing the timeline making you feel
good would be following Andrew Tate what
so
what you're saying is just so the
audience understands because a lot of
the audience isn't on Twitter yeah so on
Twitter in the timeline you're seeing a
lot of cutesy videos like it'll be like
a cat or doing something or a dog or oh
it's a bear playing with a bunch of dogs
and the bear thinks it's a dog type [__]
right it basically gives you like oh
there's Hope For Humanity there's
something good oh how cute and it's some
animals
and then you look at and then you look
at the audience who Andrew Tate is
Andrew Tate is the guy that is currently
under investigation was in prison for
60 days or so or something like that I
know I think under a sex trafficking
human trafficking and now there's new
charges that he's being investigated for
in Romania which by the way he went to
Romania because he thought I would be
able to get away with this stuff because
the laws are very lackadaisical over
there
Andrew Tate is one of these 10 accounts
that these cute
animal you know feel good accounts on
Twitter are actually following so Elon
what does that mean the new CEO all
these other people and Andrew Tate what
I believe these accounts actually are
is an attempt and now they've they've
also uh they've also been around since
2020 2021 stuff like that so these are
older accounts these are older older
accounts now what I think have oh and
not only that but it turns out
that if you go to their because some of
these have subscriptions right so
they're they're okay you can subscribe
to your page one of them
actually the only one
the only subscription
is to Elon Musk what the [__]
so now you have to ask yourself why is
no way yeah
so so so this account because you can go
out and people don't know this you can
go out and you can buy an older Twitter
account right like if you if you don't
want to set up a new one you're like hey
I want one that's two or three years old
maybe it has a couple hundred followers
you can go buy one from someone and
they'll they'll sell you the handle and
give you the login and it's yours so
um but what you're saying is is that
these cutesy accounts not only are
following Andrew Tate but they're paying
Elon Musk to subscribe to his account
exactly now are they blue checked
accounts
so are they paying all of all of the
accounts that this one specific one and
others are are following are blue Check
accounts so what the
functions to our blue Check accounts as
well so tell me what this means so what
I believe it means is that Elon in an
attempt to counteract all of this you
know this quote unquote hate speech
right and it's not really quote unquote
it is hate speech but to them it's to
them that they're saying like it's hate
speech like uh you know miles Ian Chong
is on is on threads and he's like oh
this place is already suppressing the
voice of DC Drano a lot of well maybe
accept the outcome of the election and
stop trying to say that vaccines cause
[__] autism right lies right like
some guy was like 99 some person today
on on thread said
uh I 99 disagree with with steel gray
which is Miles Leon Tron
but Zuck basically is suppressing uh
free speech and I said Zuckerberg you
you right now are arguing
that what he was saying which was DC
Drano
was flagged as you're going to follow an
account that has been flagged for
misinformation meaning DC Drano was
saying stuff about vaccines he was
saying stuff about the election he was
just not accepting facts and science so
I was like hey you're you're arguing
this and uh it's it's a little bit sad
to see anyway so what I think is
happening on Twitter is that
Elon in an attempt to fix this issue
right to fix this issue with oh
everyone's afraid of right-wing trolls
and the Nazis and this and fascism all
this stuff right
what I believe that Elon is doing is
using these accounts to push
artificially push them in because even
in my feed this morning I had that same
account which again I haven't interact
with I don't follow I don't read to it I
don't comment that account had three
posts in succession which almost made me
feel like I was on their page and on
their timeline so wait a second so what
you're saying is I I think I know what
you're saying now what you're saying is
elon's like look we got Nazis but we
also got kitty cats
either directly related in in connection
with Elon saying that we're partnered
with Elon or elon's gonna help promote
our account whatever the reason might be
I do believe that Elon is pushing his
finger
on the account to push them out further
to people to say oh look good stuff good
stuff good stuff good stuff doesn't fix
the fact that there's [__] fascists
and Nazis on here that you that you uh
you inflame and you project every day
onto everyone else well here speaking of
um fascists this is this is on Twitter I
can't show the threads this is the exact
no but this is the exact this is the
exact same thing right which I find
which I find funny because what I'm
noticing is that all of these right wing
cucks are going on to threads and
they're like oh check this place out
what's going on over here like it looks
like my censorship is I can't say what I
want to say
everyone is complaining you got uh pizza
boy uh Jack prostate you got fembot
miles Ian Chong you got all of these
other guys turbo Turbo sorry turbo Turbo
miles Ian okay but all of them are on
they're all complaining about the same
thing which is funny considering the
fact that no one is forcing these people
to join this app you know what's also
crazy
download the [__] app and you have to
connect it to your Instagram account you
have to you have to explicitly go to the
App Store and say Yes install oh yes
face ID got it or I type in my password
then you go to say oh yeah yes I do want
to connect my Instagram account God
connect them yes I do want to copy over
my bio and my photo and my name from my
Instagram account great now what I'm
gonna do is the first thing I'm gonna
tweet about if you're uh [__] Matt
Gates you're gonna tweet about Hunter
Biden laptop or his dick if you're Ian
miles Chong you're going to talk about
how Zuck is uh is censoring your free
speech if you're well someone else Shane
about these you're going to complain
about this app that you explicitly
joined you downloaded you connected you
wrote something you posted
and and this is what right well you say
[__] on Instagram that gets you flagged
for misinformation right um when you go
to follow DC Drano on threads
it says this is what the this is what
they're saying that the the screenshot
was says this account has repeatedly
posted false information and was
reviewed by independent fact Checkers
and went against our community
guidelines are you sure you want to
follow it
no not not really not really I mean
they're gonna they're gonna be they're
gonna [__] about this they [__] about
everything man I mean yeah that's what I
you know what I find funny about this
whole thing is that these people who are
like oh yeah free speech Elon took over
but what they noticed also while we were
off the air is that over the past
weekend there was an issue in terms of
what was happening with Twitter and how
people could use it you know that's why
that's why I checked out really honestly
gotcha because I was like understandable
I understand you know because I was I
was like okay I'm gonna stay up with the
news but then the rate limit thing came
like [__] it I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna put it all away for five days
right [__] that [__] so and that's what
I also look at like this is really poor
timing or good timing depending on how
you look at it as the you know outside
Observer but I I look at the situation
and I say Elon [__] over because he
said
he was
um
they claimed that they were paying
Google for their Google cloud services
and that's that's their server right
that's what they have and what they
ended and what they were supposed to do
is
Port over to their own server
if you're a company that has the means
of paying for your own server or uh or
or building your own data center so that
you can actually house this yourself and
not pay an outside third party service
like AWS or Google cloud services or
whatever it might be then you'll
probably do that and it might be the
more wise thing to do in terms of cost
cutting measures especially when you owe
1.5 billion dollars on an interest
payment for a 44 billion dollar purchase
that you made for a company that seems
to be a bit of a clunker and the new
models out and actually alternative
models are out now which you're seeing
are you know blue sky and threads oh
yeah they want me to join Blue Sky last
week I'm like Jesus Christ people so
what I'm what I'm seeing here is that
Elon Musk [__] over the deadline to
renew the contract was June 30th July
1st came around and the app [__] hit
the [__] fan like the [__] was
hitting the fan and it was blowing back
in everybody's face and that's what was
happening with the rate limit exceeded
everyone's like I can't I looked at 200
messages I looked at 200 tweets I looked
at 400 tweets whatever the message was
originally was 400 and 600 then 800 then
a thousand I think or something like
that or 600 800 a thousand
and Elon not from the official Twitter
account not from the new CEO nothing
like that Elon was the one to say that
oh well we have to fix this issue and
everyone's being rate limited and they
can see that the first or they can see
600 tweets for free and this and that
and all this [__] and if you're
verified then you can see
six thousand you know and then it's and
then if you're not on the app then it's
400 or 200 and then an hour later it was
800 and then 8 000 and then it was 400
600 and then a couple hours later it was
it was a thousand ten thousand and what
what we were noticing was
a guy Elon Musk who because of a fragile
Eagle fragile ego hubris and also
incompetence had was unprepared for
something that he thought he could treat
the same way as the rent on the Twitter
buildings was it well I don't pay I
don't have to deal with it and they're
gonna have to keep me and those services
like no we could just shut this [__]
down and we don't have to make it work
for you anymore because you're not
paying and we're well within our right
it's easy as that it's a it's you know
software just as a service you can
easily shut off so that's what happened
and he was trying to what I believe is
try to reconfigure everything whether
Port over to new server or kind of get
things back up rolling by paying Google
cloud services and that is why we had
that whole issue this weekend where
everything seemed to be unable to fetch
new data because every view that you
would go through basically when you go
through your your feed
every impression counts as a view
remember that's how video views are
counted right so you're saying so you're
saying scroll through like this
on your phone
you're gonna you're gonna wipe through
most of that that allotted views that
you were given right and that was the
problem so when did all that stop when
did the rate limit stop because I only
noticed it for like a day or two so
July 1st I think was a Saturday so
Sunday it was still someone effect and I
think like by Monday it had begun to get
a little bit better some people were
saying some people were saying uh
that they couldn't even DM people
really well that was that was one of the
only things that I could do was DM and
then and then I could uh uh get in
Twitter spaces but but I you know I got
I had to use like all my stock accounts
if I wanted to go look at something I
had to use a shotgun to go look at this
nothing was working and all of the links
I mean even I was you know I was messing
with you and I was like I can't even see
no I can't even if I click a link from a
text that I get from you like if you
were to share with me okay let's go back
let's go back for a second so do you
think do you think something happened
because this it seems really suspicious
that that all happened right before
threads released now I just think I just
conspiracy thing then no D State I just
think it's straight up incompetence wow
and it just it just happened to fall it
was it was a public deadline people knew
about this deadline which is June 30th
and they had to pay their bill and on
June 20th 21st because when it was
originally announced in the beginning of
June they said Twitter has a deadline
with Google and they have to pay them
for these Services by June 30th before
the contract expires and when the
contract expires then boom
no bueno bada boom so yeah okay so it
was by like June 20th when
um they they updated to tell everyone
don't worry we paid the bill we're
paying the bill we gotta figure out I
highly doubt that because what we saw on
June 30th or on July 1st so
I heard a story the only story I really
heard over the weekend
was that um someone found some cocaine
in the White House is that true it was
mine was it it was mine it looks it
looks like it was yours
look at what did I tell you man I I just
kept running and running I was you know
I was left to my own I had no idea what
was going on I had no sense of time I
did not know what day it was I didn't
even know what time it was but I went in
I'm sure if you look through
um White House footage the CCTV you'll
notice a person that looks relatively
like me my hair wasn't as long it was
probably like half that length right and
if you notice me going around
what's the story about the cocaine
though did they really find the highest
office in the land my friend
um but it definitely it definitely made
for a very energizing tour of the White
House while we were there you know it
was a very um so are they passing out
eight people in the conversation they
were not passing out eight balls they
were like mini you know okay they were
like mini four balls oh I see you know I
can get you I mean yeah it's just one of
those things where you go you go there
and they give you a little sample like
when you're at Costco and you drive okay
you know kind of thing it's just just
the one bump kind of thing yeah just a
single bump not a not a ton you know
okay well you know what's funny is
there's this Hunter Biden video of
course Hunter Biden was at the White
House over the weekend because
um oh yeah his dad is the president
that's probably why right and they hung
out on the holiday in that sort of weird
how families hang out on holidays that's
weird you know I could tell you who
didn't hang out with the family in the
hallway yeah Don Jr didn't he did him
and Kimberly break up I heard they bro I
have I do not have confirmation people
were but I heard this and I'm like I
don't know I know I have time to look
this [__] up
but do you think do you think Don Jr is
scared that Kimberly is uh turned turned
on him and she's uh cooperating with the
feds so now she he broke up with her is
that what you think
honestly at this point it's anyone's
game we got Rusty Bowers we got you know
other people that are coming yeah uh
coming along I'm gonna come
um well um well NADA apparently is uh
they're gonna try to arraign him for the
third time
uh today did they Reign him I think yeah
he pleaded not guilty yeah yeah
you know what's weird about that is that
uh he still trumps valet and they can't
they can't technically talk about their
case because they're co-conspirators so
here's another little uh another little
aspect to the coke problem the the
cocaine problem the cocaine problem okay
does this have to do if you want not on
Donald Trump so you remember the the red
button yeah the coke the diet coke right
well coke coke well right yeah Joe Biden
there was coke in the white house I
guess Joe Biden Joe Biden has a red
button oh that can send in ice cream
I don't know I thought you were I
thought you're gonna say Biden has a
cocaine button Donald Trump had a diet
coke button Joe Biden has a cocaine
button no no no no no no this is what
happened Joe Biden has an ice cream
button right and it sends someone in
with the brand new fresh ice cream okay
right very cool I wish I had that I'd
probably be like 300 pounds if I had
someone who just bringing me ice cream
in right
however
over the weekend I was informed that the
button was under maintenance so they had
a replacement and they had to pull it
out from the archives turns out that
button was Donald Trump's coke button
really
yeah huh so if we do the math here the
my the meganomics the magonomics if you
notice that a replacement red button was
in was in the was on the desk the
Resolute desk there in the Oval Office
turns out that was not actually Joe
Biden's button it was Donald Trump's
button and that is why the coke just
happened to show up I see I see well you
know
all these stories
you know talking about the cocaine in
the White House like Kimberly's you know
Don Junior's breaking up with Kimberly
Hunter Biden's on the balcony can you
get me I I can't find the full clip of
Hunter Biden wiping sweat off his brow
and then picking up his kid and showing
him the fireworks they cut it down to
where he's just wiping his brow and they
act like he's he's twitching or
something I'm like dude if you launch
the whole clip everyone's sweating her
balls off because it's like a thousand
degrees in DC on the fourth of July and
they're outside watching fireworks in
suits like who the [__] why the [__] are
you people in suits you know put a
T-shirt and some shorts on some
flip-flops it's [__] July it's summer
get your get your it's gonna be lit
shirt on you know what I mean yeah that
not all right let's get lit right I mean
hunter Biden I'm sure and I'm sure
Hunter Biden had a few bumps in his
pocket I'm not saying that maybe he did
maybe didn't I know he's trying to
recover from his addiction but the dude
might still meet [__] doing bumps of
coke I don't know I don't have the full
clip this is a clip after yeah that's
where they're saying he did a bump
because he touched his nose that's like
people in the chat all the haters when I
when I'm messing with my mustache like
oh you're picking your nose I mean
sometimes I might have to pick my nose
I got itchies man I got itchies do you
got itchies today there beard man uh I
definitely have itchies today I mean
there's a i if you give me a moment I
just gotta go shave real quick okay all
right go ahead go shave and then we'll
let's see if I can pull this up
um this Hunter Biden video because
they're [__] ridiculous they're
[__] ridiculous
um okay so this is the um this is the
part where they think he's doing a bump
um on the balcony so so you're gonna
watch him walk behind oh man that was
fast
huh
there we go there we go so you're just
gonna shave you're not gonna get a
haircut yet no not yet not yet no I'm
still I'm still trying to figure out
exactly the style I want I'll add just
one thing I can get the beard off no
problem but the hair it's a whole other
thing I gotta go in and get a specialist
you know they're saying on Twitch
manscape emergency listen I I didn't I
didn't know people were saying I look
like a I look like lady Gabe really well
you know oh look at Stargell 46 now you
look like a lady Gabe sorry man well
Wayne's World flashback way better Gabe
there's all kinds of them and there's
probably a ton on YouTube but we can't
see it right now I wish I could see
those things I'm sure people are
roasting me right now
the man just grow out his hair this this
clip that you're gonna see in your game
is um Hunter Biden now this is where
they're saying he did a bump
I'm saying dude had a booger but you
know what do I know I don't think I mean
if he's gonna do something listen one
bump isn't gonna [__] with Hunter do you
think like one one little bump of coke
is no I mean dude the dude is done Coke
and smoke crack for a long time dude's
gonna have to do a line in the bathroom
all right he's gonna have to lay it out
on the on this on the counter and
[__] do a line he's not gonna get
high with a bump okay you [__] idiots
but one but watch let's let's see if he
let's see well every drug is equal to
them Tony they don't know
some of them might know actually but
they love to say one bump what hit
that's the one that takes you all the
way to [__] we're Loathing in Las
Vegas what do they give a [__] if he's
doing coke anyways what do they ever
cared about [__] Junior right I mean
Jesus Christ you watch one clip of that
[__] podcast triggered when he
is triggered in the podcast holy you're
like Jesus Christ dude Jack Jordan the
[__] bunny ears the [__] eyeballs
he's like yeah just [__] nuts man you
know it's a projection well I mean
obviously but let's let's see if you can
spot where Hunter does the bump here
[Music]
turn that sound off see and we'll watch
it again see if you can spot it huh he's
sweating like he's in there he's been
he's sweating his balls off look look at
look at the first lady she is shining
yeah she is shiny and I I doubt
that Dr Jill Biden is gonna go out and
not powder and stuff before so you know
there it's just hotter than a
[__] up there I mean it's got to
be a thousand degrees on that belt it
was the hottest day on record well it is
true that is uh that's a new new thing
that we got today too is that we've
reached the hottest point of our Earth
that we've measured it before but here
watch it again this evening spot there
is it really that's not doing a bump man
he goes
swiping the sweat and he wipes the sweat
off his nose and then a bump goes like
this I dude this is the first spot where
I usually get where I'm like I notice I
sweat the first it's either like comes
down the side right it's running off
your forehead down your nose now look
hey if Hunter Biden's doing a bump I
don't give a [__] I'd point it out I'm
like yeah he's doing a [__]
he's totally doing now he may be going
to do a line
I mean [__] going off the
balcony he may needed a little pick me
up here so I'm not saying he's not going
to do a line in the bathroom I'm not
saying that but that ain't a bump come
on man if you're gonna [__] get this
right get it right
get it right it just doesn't ambiguous
it doesn't add up if we were able to see
a full angle you know the full view
right then this wouldn't even mean
question
I'm sure I'm sure someone online is
gonna say oh look how Jill Biden is
perfectly in view in blocking Hunter
Biden so we can take a bump off his
[__]
thumb you know the other thing that I
noticed about Twitter over the last week
or two you said the the kitty cat
accounts yes I now Twitter and Elon may
be on to me here but they've been just
feeding me boobs like just boobs nice
what about you has that been in your
phone I don't have boobs oh my God it
just now it's probably because I stop
and I'm like oh that there's those are
boobs well you know if you uh if you
stop and take a gander they're gonna
register that I may click into the
account and see if there's some more
boobs on that account I'm not gonna lie
I'm not opposed to porn being on Twitter
some people are like oh that's
disgusting but see look at that I've got
people I've got people the only thing
I've got I've got [__] porn stars
that follow me which is hilarious
look here okay and and some of these
some of these uh women who post the
pictures of their boobs think they're
they're doing the world the service
really honestly but a lot of them are
liberals okay and then and then they
speak out they're outlines of the lgbtq
community so I probably follow some of
these it's probably why they're getting
my timeline but see there's there's
boobs go down up there's another set of
boobs uh go down just a little bit
where's that where's that headphone
going is that on interaboose I mean no
no no no no no here fixing to rain oh oh
it looked like it was going in I
couldn't see okay okay yeah thanks for
the zoomed in view I wanted to know you
wanna I know
are you going keep going keep going oh
there's a boat someone fishing okay yeah
up boops
I'm telling you man are you searching
for boobs no if I'm gonna search for
boobs I'm gonna go to Pornhub I'm just
saying it just it's all my time see you
there you go this is true man I'm just
showing you there's a fair you're I mean
the amount of boobs you have in there
these selfies yeah the selfie that sell
see yeah I'm telling you look the legs
there's a set of legs
it probably doesn't help that you keep
uh searching I mean this is my timeline
this is my timeline now and again it's
the fight videos I got a lot of fight
videos in my timeline too I've seen a
fair amount of oh those are the other
accounts I've been seeing lately which
is
uh no context Clips or right they're
like oh my God this person just stood in
front of a train just a weird clip and
then they were killed and I'm like why
the [__] is this on Twitter yeah it's
like murder porn right
see there's there's another boobs
I I and again I I don't know what it is
maybe it's the more you talk about look
at those hot dogs the more you talk
about boobs the more Twitter is
listening to be like the boy wants me I
guess so boys let's get him some more
booze see there's ass shaking there and
see oh wow it's just that's what I'm
getting on my Twitter feed wow and maybe
they got me figured out maybe the
algorithms got me figured out of how to
stay on Twitter right but listen I'm
gonna be honest Elon showing me a bunch
of pictures of boobs is not getting me
to stay on Twitter it's getting me to go
to a different website to be quite
honest with you and it's not I'm not
saying if you're going to look at it you
have to wonder why am I why do I need to
scroll through 100 accounts to find five
boobs right when I can just go one where
there is all boobs it's all boobs well I
mean it's me the kind of boobs that I
want it to be like you just search
right you tell what you want it'll feed
it to you and then you know 30 seconds
later you're back on Twitter
what what zero days we've been back
we've been back for less than two hours
and here we are you with your long hair
and us talking about porn you look like
you look like a porn star from the late
80s that's what this is I'm wait hold on
like I was in the 80s and it's today or
I'm in the 80s as a porn star it's from
the 19 you look like a porn star from
the 1980s possibly like I'm a porn star
in the 1980s yeah sure like like I am a
I am in uh shut the [__] up I'm just
trying to understand like I'm from like
I didn't know if you meant I'm a porn
star that has now aged you know and I'm
in 2023 40 years later or if this really
is me in the 80s as a porn star you know
these guys did you hear about moms of
Liberty
did you hear the nicknames they got Clan
no I I've I've heard I've heard some
Planned Parenthood
there's twatsis what's this there's
[__] with casseroles I've heard that
one yeah that's a good there's another
one that's a Taliban one yeah uh the
mini the minivan Taliban yeah that's
what the minivan
uh the moms of Liberty they really [__]
the bed didn't they they really like
they got a huge National following hey
we love Hitler and everyone's like whoa
whoa whoa what they they're on threads
as well yeah and they're first oh [__]
their first post let me just pull it up
so I can read it specifically I wish I
could I wish I could show the the screen
actually
um I don't know I have to try it
tomorrow are they gonna have a desktop
version sooner threads are they gonna do
that because that's what we need Maybe
oh they might but it's definitely not on
the road map right now because they know
that mobile users are probably the ones
that are like that's where you use
it mostly for them in terms of mobile
right so they could I mean they could
they could I mean look they've got a lot
planned from what I've read I mean
they're talking about decentralizing it
connecting it to Mastodon so people
could Port over their accounts on either
way
yeah they're not trying to centralize it
like Twitter they're actually trying to
do something similar to Blue Sky and
Mastodon and where it's decentralized
and uncoupled so that way so that way
you can go post on threads and it'll go
and anyone can look well I don't know if
it's post on threads that would be able
to go somewhere else or if it's you can
connect and find other people or if it's
directly porting over your account from
one to the other I'm not exactly sure
yet this sounds like Zuckerberg really
is gonna [__] with Elon though yeah yeah
I mean do you think do you think
Twitter's dead now or do you think I
mean I I said on threads this morning I
said I don't know if Twitter's dead but
it definitely has terminal hate cancer
for sure it's certainly it certainly
does and the thing that Mom uh moms for
Liberty posted on their account was
comments something you found in your
child's school that you think shouldn't
have been there a lot of people about
moms of Liberty how about moms a lot of
people are saying you you moms for
Liberty my my response was specifically
naming uh Tina kovich Tiffany Justice
and Bridget Ziegler which are the the
founders of them
um [__] them twatsies that's the one I
like the best twice
[__] and casseroles is pretty good
too and plant and claim Karen Hood
that's pretty good I think it was the
the other one was Mary KKK
every guess begins with KKK
[__]
you think you think what do you what do
you outrage is over the week
of the week about threads
um throttling Twitter
what do you think you think you think
we're gonna cross that Rubicon where
they're just freaking out they're like
oh my God these things are sinking ship
or do you think by the weekend people
are like okay if you're gonna be if
you're gonna be in the left-wing Echo
chamber you're gonna go on threads I'll
say this there's already been over 5
million people that have joined threads
in the last less than 24 hours
what people are now wondering is you
know will it sustain itself I think so I
think what I read is a couple days ago I
read that like 18
of Facebook's user base right has to
join and use or just join
um
Facebook or meta threads to compete with
Twitter
really yeah because because Facebook is
the biggest right isn't it the biggest
yes as far as user base
10 are they
again and Twitter's not even the top ten
of user base in this country let's see
in the United States
oh in the United States yeah yes it is
it's like 90 top 10. no no it is top 10.
her Twitter is it Twitter is the largest
company largest country of users
of their whole of all of the countries
and and continents around
the one in the U.S is the one that's
pushing the activity than anywhere and
then anywhere else that they have users
around the world it's uh MJ is saying
over 30 million already as of two hours
ago see there you go it's just been a
it's like it's gonna be fast well you
know you know what you know what's uh is
significant about that and I noticed
this morning that that [__] did not
slow down some people are saying it's
glitching but my app did not [__] up
which I was like oh breads yeah I do I
am one I am part of the small percentage
of people that I cannot add uh photo or
video right now which is unfortunate but
just means that that's because you were
in the first half million and like [__]
you yeah
but it could be
yeah
so you don't get a video [__] what's
happening what's happening is I posted
the thumbnail for the show on there yeah
that's great that you could but when I
go into what the [__] you want me man
yeah
I'm just seeing all the memes right now
which is like uh people people uh like
BuzzFeed they've got one that says me
logging into threads knowing this is
going to consume my life for the next 12
years and then it's a photo which I
don't think you could oh yeah you could
kind of see it yeah that's the other
thing that I couldn't do this morning is
look up News because I was on this
threads thing trying to figure it out
yeah but you know what is breaking news
uh watch this this is hilarious it's
about the economy watch Steve what do
you have I got 497
000 I got a double take number here that
you have to look at and say is this
right that's the number ADP providing
for their estimate of the growth
actually it's no longer an estimate of
the growth BLS number it's just their
ass what was that
you know what's funny is uh they got a
double take on on the economy very nice
okay so we we've been doing this show
for a while and last year in 2022 a lot
of people
um were like oh the economy [__] it's
gonna go downhill there's gonna be a
recession blah blah blah I said look
they're intentionally drawing up the
interest rates to try to drive us into a
recession and the demand is still up
so when demand is high and and consumers
are demanding product or Services you're
not going to have a recession right you
can you can try to make money more
expensive which they've done
they've tried to make money more
expensive which is it which is a good
tactic in some situations to fight
inflation right because what you're
trying to do is not overheat demand
you're trying to push back on it to Tamp
down inflation but really our inflation
has been all artificial and what I mean
by that is it's artificial from the
pandemic it's still a systemic problem
that came from the pandemic because our
entire country was shut down the economy
was shut down and then we have
corporations intentionally inflating
their Pro their their prices right it's
not it's just it's not real it's it's
[__] fake they're taking advantage of
the demand and the market
but it clearly is it clearly the economy
is still on the right track right this
is June's numbers of total private
payroll was up almost a half million now
this isn't the government's numbers okay
this is ADP payrolls numbers are way up
good service is up non-farm payrolls up
now
this morning the stock market's down and
the reason why is because investors are
like oh [__] this is way better than we
thought it was going to be
so you know what's going to happen is
there's going to be more demand which is
going to drive more inflation which is
going to make the feds raise the
interest rate and now we're [__] as
investors so so they get kind of weird
right so it's getting weird so we got
really good numbers this morning for
payroll
but the market responded the opposite
way because the rich people in this
country
it's not going the way they thought it
would go like they you know speaking of
the economy to go to [__] is what they
want I mean speaking of rich people yeah
it was a comment that was made
in the last day or so
by a certain somebody you know what I
think I got that here I think I got that
here this is a Jess Piper headed on her
her account um I think you're talking
about this one from uh I've got the I've
got the the larger screen version well
I'm going to show Jess is here and then
we'll show the larger one well if you
can get the extended one for me but
listen to what the fly on Mike Pence's
head says here
I don't really buy into the
listen do it again
[Music]
I don't really buy into the rich need to
pay their fair share he doesn't really
buy into the rich needing to pay their
fair share huh that seems kind of funny
it almost feels like
Jess is right when she says you're
saying the client part out loud dude
what are you what are you doing man
that's how they're working now man they
they really have no other option but to
say the quiet part out loud well hope
that those people will join them in
their fight you know just like just like
Mitt Romney and his 47 he's really in a
binders full of women he's really hoping
that if he says these things out loud to
a small group hopefully nobody's filming
oh looks like somebody filmed it [__]
well here's here's the problem here's
the problem and Mike Pence either
believes one or two things when he's
saying this in this room right he's well
let me play his comments the the full
the full uh video here it's only 20
seconds long maybe you'll get more
context and maybe it's maybe we're just
misreading this a bit here but let's see
I'm somebody that
I don't really buy into the the rich
need to pay their fair share I mean when
you look at
when you look at the
statistics of where we actually get
funding for the government top 10
percent of earners in this country I
think that I
so no he did he did say that now his
argument and there is a longer video his
argument is is that that oh the top
earners pay the most
in taxes like
yeah they make the most money so they're
gonna pay a lot even if it's a smaller
percentage that they're paying they're
still going to be more money that's the
problem that Republicans
have where you you would say that
a direct relationship between what I
work and pay and you know what you work
and pay and then what somebody who's
very wealthy should should work in Pay
there should be a direct correlation or
a a not correlation but there should be
a direct relationship to say that if I
pay 30 on my you know income tax on my
taxes or whatever that somebody who is
wealthy should pay the bare minimum that
same price
right if not more
because we know that by generate we know
we know from historical data and
behaviors and how humans work is that a
majority of these people if not all of
them when they amass wealth they do not
bring it back into the economy
trickle-down economics does not work
it's trickle up economics it does not
work the way that Reagan said it worked
he did it does not work the way in which
well if we give the wealthy in these
companies these corporations more money
they're going to trickle that money down
so all the people at the bottom of the
pyramid get the money too that isn't how
it works they make the money they cut
staff they cut resources and they
continue to amass that wealth while also
paying less in taxes and Republicans as
Mike Pence said here well I don't think
the wealthier the rich had paid the
taxes it's you know who says that the
[__] rich and the wealthy right
exactly well you know what's funny about
that that you say that because it's one
of two things I was going to say or
there either Mike Pence believes that
these people in this room Are One
percenters which they're not I don't
know if I can I don't know if I can give
you the phone I can look at all their
hair and I can determine that they are
above a certain age wow right but
they're not and they don't want to
listen they're very protective of their
pensions I'm telling you this room right
here is not a one percent a room not a
one percent these are not one percenters
these are centers
right one Centers do not have to go to
some sort of strip mall right or or or
Banquet Hall in a hotel right they don't
show up they're gonna go to Harlan
Hitler's uh Hitler Library they'll send
you there they'll bring you to their
house their mansion if anything they'll
just zoom in and they'll have someone
else watch it on their staff right
exactly they're not showing up and
sitting down in some fold-up chair so he
either believes that these are one
percenters which they are not and he
knows that or he believes that they
think they're the they're rich and
wealthy that is the best [__] part
about this whole thing is people out
there think because they're middle class
you're the rich and wealthy you are not
listen listen to me listen to me I wanna
I wanna tell you a secret and it's gonna
piss a lot of people off okay turn the
[__] the volume up a little bit here
if you're not making
household
over 500 six seven eight hundred
thousand dollars a year you got me a
year if you're not making over that
amount you are not rich you are not rich
okay I don't care if you got two three
million dollars in your retirement
account you're not rich you're just not
you're not you think you are you I I got
a lot of friends that have some money
and they and they get do what they want
they go on vacations they got a nice
house you got nice cars they think
they're rich I'm like you have no
[__] clue what rich is you have no
clue what wealth is you have no idea how
much money a billion dollars is you have
no [__] clue you couldn't even fathom
it
why do you think that they're trying to
convince you that you're one of them and
the reason why is that we don't want to
tax you who's making 400 Grand a year to
in an oblivion okay the first million
dollars whatever we can come up with
some [__] system after a million
bucks
after a hundred million dollars you
[__] ain't right we tax the whole
goddamn thing 90 [__] you [__] you you
don't need that much money and if you do
need that much money that's your problem
that isn't you problem my friend ah well
you're just you're just going after the
job creators Tony aren't you a
capitalist listen if they're job
creators then why did the richest man in
the world
supposedly the richest man in the world
by Twitter for three times as much as
it's worth for 44 billion I don't think
you [__] understand how much
money 44 billion dollars is okay I don't
think you understand it he paid 44
billion
and by the end of this weekend it's
going to be worth half of what it is
today which is the worth a third of what
it was when he bought it
so
I would actually say I would actually
say it's even less because we have to
remember that there has been a decrease
in revenue from advertisers since the
purchase the actual purchase and signing
of agreements and documents and and Elon
taking over we have to remember that
from that point is when that dip began
to happen and over the last few months
we've seen that the value or Revenue
that has been generated from advertisers
on Twitter has significantly decreased
the value of Twitter so to also go to
that point is I can't remember what the
figure was because we're way down the
next 30 days to come out on from from
internal investors
but you have something that's probably
worth even less than what you think it
is right now
right oh and again I understand that
people out there their upper middle
class
and especially if you live in the
Midwest and you're making over 200 Grand
you really think you're middle class now
I don't know hey if you're making 200
Grand well I mean you're just affording
an apartment
you're muted I don't know why but you're
muted
what'd you do I muted myself yeah
um technically what did you fart or
something no no no I uh I kept getting
notifications on my phone oh I see
um the technically they were fake well
there were figures that came out
I'm trying to keep talking and I'll pull
it up well okay so so you're not you're
not you're not rich
okay you're you're just not you might be
comfortable you might live the lifestyle
that you want to live but you're not
wealthy that's not what that is you
think you are it feels good but you're
not speaking of wealthy people um on
Twitter Zuckerberg is trending at seven
which is kind of funny and Twitter kills
this Twitter killer is training with it
it's it's funny to look at this whole
situation and say God damn it only Elon
could make me actually like Mark
Zuckerberg in this situation like I
never thought that I would be looking at
two billionaires and be like oh
where is my money going I don't believe
this look at this they say in our post
for the show is the first one in that
Zuck thread I think you're goddamn right
[__] yeah I think they're bullshitting
though maybe I think that's all [__]
maybe I think they're juicing something
over there what was the what was the
topic the trend Zuck because I said I
said that I posted from your account so
let's see if I go to that
no I posted from the Pod account not my
account oh it's a pod account not post
that I do every morning Med is trending
bird man why is oh that's something
different oh there's Bird app sorry
you're not the first one on here well it
all depends honestly on who
who you're going to get yeah see that's
what I'm saying they're juicing [__]
they're juicing it he's juicing but I
can tell you this much I can tell you
this much he's very active on threads
right now he has replaced Zuck Oh I
thought you meant Elon is Elon on
threads no someone told me last night
and I need to confirm this but somebody
told me would that be funny if
Zuckerberg like opened an official
account open that [__] for him just
open that [__] up let me see
Elon did with Trump like please come
please come tweet please someone someone
posted last night that Elon had deleted
his Instagram account I never checked it
and I just checked right now and it's
still it's still there so he so Elon
because he has an Instagram account he
technically has a threads account he
technically has a threads account that
would be at Elon Musk right on threads
but
he has yet to join I'm sure let's see
actually if I were to search for Elon
Musk in Threads right now it'd probably
pull up a [__] ass [__]
oh my God
uh I wish I had better stuff for the day
back I thought we were gonna have all
kinds of stuff I got the Walt NADA thing
if you want to see Walt Nana walk into
the courthouse sure yeah yeah let's see
let's see waltene uh walking to the
courthouse here and I got that um I got
that footage uh here you go here's
here's Walt teen uh Donald Trump's
co-conspirator in the Espionage charges
walking into the courthouse there in
Miami
okay
riveting stuff
super exciting yep ooh baby let me tell
you something corruption corruption and
crime generally when it starts to be
indicted and get into court it it gets
pretty boring it's not sexy until you
actually can hear the arguments and you
can hear the testimony and you can
actually see the witness or when the
jury and or judge give the final ruling
on what the outcome is although I didn't
see if Grandpa did he did he post about
it on true social to see if um
and that someone else who technically
has a a threads account no [__] which by
the way it looks like they're already
fact checking down junior
John junior is on threads so he's
posting he's posting and and and his
first post let me let me get the full
thing hold on
what the [__] oh [__] he's Grandpa he's
he posted in the last day about the
cocaine thing I gotta pull oh you didn't
see that no I I man I I just knew that
there was cocaine found in the White
House 51 minutes ago Donald Trump Jr I
figured and also it looks like he tabbed
in for a second I don't know why I did
that I figured I'd give this a shot
scene as quite a few people on Twitter
are trying to blame me for the cocaine
in the white house question mark
exclamation point question mark LOL I
mean I haven't been there in almost
three years and there's someone with a
serious problem so you're saying you're
saying you brought cocaine this just
this time it wasn't used is that what
he's saying because that's what it feels
like yeah yeah yeah but I'm not done
look at this it says uh that was
apparently there he's spelled there
wrong uh he spelled it t-h-e-i-r I do
that
but anyway heavily guarded but no one
knows anything I'm shocked and then the
party blow whistle with the party hat
face on
he's he's
[Music]
um
why why do we have to sit here and
debate who's the bigger cokehead son
Donald Trump Jr and Hunter Biden why do
we have to do that it sounds really
stupid like I don't really know idea but
I asked that question oh I was gonna say
I asked a question last night do we
consider this like are is Elon and Zuck
still gonna fight or are we just going
to consider this a dub
and I no I want him to fight I hope they
fight yeah hell out of each other I
think I know it's funny you like full on
cage match with like Bob our bats and
[__] but you know what's funny is
remember how we talked about how elon's
mom was like no I won't let him fight
guess who well said he shouldn't fight
who his dad the weird dad oh my God the
damn dad every woman in the world
that he doesn't want Elon to fight
because it's gonna be humiliating
and the reason he said is Elon will lose
no matter what if he wins he loses and
if he loses he loses because if he wins
he looks like a bully and if he loses he
just looks like a a loser
shitty
it would look pretty shitty if you got
your ass kicked by Mark Zuckerberg like
I don't you know a lot of people like oh
he's training he's lifting weights and
all this [__] he's a badass come on the
idea that you know [__] break the
idea that
Elon Musk can take a crash course in MMA
or Muay Thai or Jitsu or whatever it
might be in a 30-day period to be like I
have like he's not Neo from The Matrix
he can't just download all of this these
skills oh no oh he's got that new chip
[__] if he puts in that
CyberLink that might be the right thing
when you guys when you've got Zuck who
has been training for a considerable
amount of time and didn't didn't uh
until recently come out publicly and
have his first few matches did you
actually see the guy and you're like oh
man he's actually is looking Slimmer and
more muscular and he's actually fighting
in these tournaments
why I mean here's the thing when you're
this Rich when you're that rich an
actual wealth like ungodly amounts of
money you can afford the best dietitians
right you can afford the best [__]
there's no there's no excuse for Elon
right right you can you can afford the
best uh trainers you can afford the best
equipment you can afford the best the
best exercise plan the best anaerobic
aerobic plan there's all sorts of things
that you could do right there's so many
things that you could do with that
amount of money to appear that you're
tough right I mean you do all kinds of
things you could even pay people to lose
matches to you you could
and it still doesn't mean that you're
not Mark Zuckerberg or Elon Musk come on
and also
Elon is the one who is out there touting
ozembic
where he was like oh yeah it was done
because a good drug to take if you want
to lose weight which everyone's like no
don't don't take this unless you
actually have because I think it was for
diabetes uh that's what Elon said yeah
it's for so he's out there on Twitter
telling millions of people yeah go take
this drug yeah for diabetes but it's a
but it's I mean people use it as a
people who actually
have issues with obesity can take it
when it is carefully
prescribed and modern moderated
but that's his brain that's his brain he
knows he's on Twitter being like Oh I'm
yeah ozembic it's good you know this and
yeah why I mean just get your private
doctor to do blood tests three times a
week and take it it's not gonna I mean
it won't cost you that much it only cost
you you know several hundred thousand
dollars a month it's not that big of a
deal that's his brain that's what his
brain does speaking of brains that do
weird [__] here's Donald Trump about the
cocaine I didn't see this till just now
why didn't I see this still just now
I was on break I I don't know if this
happened when I was stoned or drunk or
both it says where are the White House
security tapes I'm just reading it like
he types it folks what do you want from
me like the ones I openly and happily
gave to drains Jack Smith
they took those you [__] that was part
of the search for what are you talking
about he says which will quickly show
where the cocaine why did he capitalize
cocaine why in the White House came from
why would why would the security tapes
at the White House know where this
cocaine came from because well what's
the situation with the good game they
already know the answer but probably
don't like it so is he is he is he
alluding to that Hunter brought the
cocaine in is that what he's saying it
seems that he's I wouldn't doubt it
would you doubt would you doubt if
Hunter Biden I think Hunter Biden
definitely would bring cocaine into the
White House yeah look I'm not saying he
he would not bring cocaine in I'm not
sure if he did bring cocaine in right
that's to be determined but also these
people are like oh man you have to you
you can't you know there was a press
conference yesterday and they were
asking about this cocaine story right
and they kept saying
um or they kept asking you know what's
what's
the press secretary
ow they were they were asking like do
you have any comment on this story about
the cocaine that's found in the White
House do you have any you know store do
you have a explanation you have this
that she's like well let me just tell
you right now we don't know anything the
secret service is going to investigate
and when they come back without their
report
we'll deal with it and we have full
confidence that they can do their job
and investigate
but we won't say anything and we won't
change anything because a lot of the
questions then delved into well if
someone could come up okay with cocaine
what's to say that somebody couldn't
come in with another white powdery
substance or another thing because those
are things that you just don't detect
for when you go through a metal detector
or something of the sort so
press secretary was like look let's just
give it a Beat Can you just like hold
off wait for the report in the
investigation to come back and then
we'll let you know once we know what's
going on but until then we don't it's
all speculation
and I'm not going to say something for
certain that I have no idea about
so well there's a clip apparently that
manga is pissed off about with Kaylee
mcinany not the
um not the current press secretary
yeah milk toast milk toast
um apparently
I don't know if this is it or not but
this is
um where on Fox and Friends where
they're asking her about the cocaine
story let's see what she says we don't
know if this FanDuel on that cocaine too
that's the problem uh you saw that
Robert De Niro's grandson just died uh
fentanyl was in whatever substance he
bought at the White House fentanyl at
the White House
they don't know what's in it he thought
he was buying one drug fentanyl was in
it do we know that fentanyl's in this
cocaine I mean
at CBS said this could have been a
non-magnetic powder that could have made
it through Anthrax this is a huge
national security threat in the Press
well they're just like oh give me a
break man people are bringing weed and
drugs into the White House
that's I don't know I can't it feels
like it's not no it doesn't feel like
that's what it is but I'm telling you
see if you find it listen there are
plenty of drugs in the White House okay
drugs come in and out of that place
every [__] day dumb [__]
especially when Trump was in do you have
any idea the cokeheads Jesus Christ do
you remember the Madison cawthorne thing
the cocaine orgies yeah of course there
was cocaine in the White House and Trump
was there come on give me a break the
amount of Adderall that that guy [__]
had in his in his pride in the private
residence give me a break
get the [__] out of here this is
nonsense oh I see I see that's not the
clip the actual so I'm looking for the
clip right here
but this is the quote it says for it to
be Hunter Biden he left on Friday he was
at Camp David there's no way it's
inconceivable to think cocaine would sit
for a 72-hour period so I rule him out
at this point they're mad because she
brought
God I hate to say it facts
to the table she said look this
is the timeline of events and it could
not have happened this way so it
couldn't have been him
oh that is why they're mad that's why
they're upset I'll try to find the video
clip of her saying that well
again this is really [__] stupid
and the reason why this is stupid is
because of course there's drugs in the
White House have you ever heard the
story about Willie Nelson
smoking weed
on the roof of the White House
when Jimmy Carter was in office you
never heard that story no Willie Nelson
tells a story all the time that he
smoked weed at the White House which
means he brought weed in Elvis listen to
me Elvis went to visit [__] Nixon you
don't think that [__] didn't
have some drugs in his pocket come on
man he's Elvis they're gonna let him in
[__] he could have venting all our
Anthrax you're like what's that for he's
like I'm gonna I'm gonna take it later
I'm gonna take it later and then totally
I mean that guy
Elvis was on a lot of stuff yeah he was
yeah he was he probably did Anthrax I'm
just saying hey [__]
[Music]
I don't know
is that I don't know is that a good
Elvis it's probably not a good Elvis I
don't know if he's a I don't I have no
idea dick
[Music]
I don't know I've been to Graceland by
the way I have not been to Graceland
I've been to Graceland it's not that
impressive it's pretty cool I mean it's
really cool but it's not the impressive
size because back then Mansions weren't
yeah as big as they are now
it just it just looks like a [__]
really big house in a cul-de-sac
neighborhood now just saying oh did you
find this clip of Kaylee I want to sh if
we can when I find this clip of of
Kaylee I want a picture yes okay we'll
have to play it from mediate because
they have it it looks like oh on the
website on Twitter itself everyone kept
quoting what she'd said not yeah
that's because you gotta show the video
for these guys because they're not gonna
believe it you know what you gotta drive
what you said just thinking of that that
could be one of the downfalls to this
threads thing right this could be an
example that a lot of people aren't
going to go grab the video and post it
on Twitter to piss these [__]
off right because because I believe what
I believe is going to happen is threads
and Twitter are going to become Echo
Chambers that's what I believe here over
the next 18 months two years are going
to become Echo Chambers so people that
are on Twitter are either [__] right
Wingers are trolling right Wingers yeah
and people on threads are either left
Wingers or people trolling I will say
the nice thing about having threads
connected to Instagram and vice versa is
that people can easily find me on either
platform and verify that I am that
person right Dennis oh great you have an
Instagram cool let me follow oh you have
a thread it's cool let me follow boom so
it is it is nice it does make my job a
lot easier in terms of trying to uh
because I can also then share content
easily not that I couldn't before but
when you're working within the same
um ecosystem of threads and now I don't
know I don't know but I'm gonna have to
disagree so like I I want to address
both your points here which is you you
guys think that read write Edward says
threads will become liberal gab right so
just to finish my thought what I was
saying is I think uh that it will be
great in terms of
sharing content if you're in the same
ecosystem right if I'm in if I'm in
Instagram and they share the content
over to Twitter or vice versa or uh over
to threads and threads you know possibly
over to Instagram in terms of having a
post I think that'll be huge I think
that'll be huge is Instagram post gonna
show up in Threads now you uh not at the
moment but you can share just like you
can share to another platform like
Twitter or a text message or something
like that you can you can share your
post
onto threads oh okay oh I I haven't done
that yet so that's the closest thing
that's the closest thing I can get to
sharing a video in a photo right now
other than re-uh re-threading someone
and or re reposting someone's original
thread on on threads or post on threads
whatever we want to call it right right
now to address this Echo chamber thing I
don't think it's going to become a
left-wing Echo chamber or it's going to
be a left-wing gab or something like
that to be a gab you have to be [__]
crazy out there anti-semitic right right
what you don't think I don't you don't
think I'm gonna say some crazy [__] over
there if you don't say look what I'm
gonna say is if you don't say
I mean you can still you can still
spread misinformation I mean you'll get
fact checked you know but I don't think
it's going to be that extreme I think
it'll be left leaning but I definitely
see people in there they're already
trying to come in right now to spread
certain things and [__] and moan about
other things and well but do you think I
don't think because of do you think it's
because of Cambridge well do you think
because of the debacle with Cambridge
analytica in 2016 the Facebook meta as
it is is more prepared to [__]
throttle the misinformation and the
[__] it could be but they also have
rolled back I think they've rolled back
covet and they did a lot of that [__] so
oh yeah
it's not gonna be left wing because
they're still assuming you don't do
anything that that violates their
Community guidelines I still think that
you're going to find
um right-wing people on there they're
still going to try to bleed stuff in I
don't think it'll be as effective but I
definitely don't think it's gonna be
like a left-wing gab or it's gonna be a
left-wing Echo chamber I think Twitter
for sure Twitter for sure the the
ability for Threads to get such a high
conversion of people that were like I
mean Joy Reid for the last few weeks
have been talking [__] like even most
recently when she did her takedown of
Vivek Ram Swami she's like I don't
really even go on Twitter anymore like I
have an account but like I'm not over
there so when when you when you look at
the comparison you have to say
Twitter will for sure be right wing
right there's no one there's no one that
is stopping them but I I have to imagine
that the the threads will be left
leaning
but I I still think that there's going
to be stuff in the that'll come into
question there
um when it when it comes to the actual
well we're still gonna have to go to
Twitter and piss these [__] off like
this clip here of Kaylee uh defending
Hunter against and Brian
oh [__]
Carl or general of course get the [__]
out of here man
for that ad yeah they gotta pay us this
[__] taste the tsunami Mountain Dew
looks like pissed yeah um come on get
the and I need to get an ad blocker I
guess I need to take the advice yeah
dude get the ad block that's what I got
yeah well okay here's here's the here's
the here's the clip today to actually
have on the Kirby couch Kaylee mcinany
who worked in the west wing for other a
good portion of American history and you
can help us figure out good works in
American history to start countries over
this heavily trafficked area we just
showed uh you know the west wing with
the Marine guard outside the very
familiar gate uh that's not the door
we're talking about as well no so if
you're looking at the White House there
over if you're looking at it directly
over to the right uh there okay this is
a really long clip and I'm not sure what
the part they're pissed off about but
I'll find it no no no no no no no no no
no no here's what I'm saying
my guess is my guess is is that not only
Kaylee mcenany has probably brought
cocaine into the White House but ducey's
son
okay I found it I found it go to three
go to 3 20 go to 320. 320. yeah
well there we are okay we're close all
right here this is where Ducey starts
asking the questions guests of family
members go in the East Wing it's not
like they would come through the West
Wing so as to diminish that you know the
rumor that it was somehow related to
Hunter Biden but unfortunately because
it's cocaine people are thinking Hunter
Biden thinking about the president and
the weird situation you see how they're
navigating this right now
gave us gave us do what
do you see how he's framing the question
yeah they got to be careful because they
can't they can't go after him and be
like now we're not saying it was him
right but a lot of people are thinking
it was him right but that's because the
issue is is that Hunter Biden has
threatened to sue for defamation because
in fact we're saying that many people
other people we're just reporting on
other people's opinions
oh okay let's see what Kaylee says to
piss off the right Wingers oh
information whatsoever I I would have
gone to Secret Service saying guys I
cannot go to the Press without some sort
of information
give me one line yeah well
she says I've got something to share the
president and the first lady in the
family we're not here this weekend
that's not news we all knew that right
um and for it to be Hunter Biden he left
on Friday he was at Camp David there is
no way it is inconceivable to think
cocaine could sit for a 72-hour period
um so I I would rule him out whoa whoa
whoa whoa I'm gonna push back here
cocaine can definitely survive a 1772
hour period come on man right we have to
also remember that you've got people
that are coming through and where'd they
find this in a doorway they're saying
yeah some some by the I think was like
the visitor area like where you enter
get the [__] out of here man this is so
stupid listen I'm telling you for sure
100 get this straight in your mind there
is a ton of drugs that walks its way in
and out of the White House I it's not
just like three people that work in that
building and to think that there aren't
[__] handfuls of people who are going
to the coke orgies
and not having a couple eight balls left
in their [__] purse or their pocket
or their suit jacket and go walking in
the White House you're out of your mind
you're out of your mind there's plenty
of drugs in the White House going in and
out it's happening and it ain't the
president and Hunter Biden it's staff
members it's all kinds of people and let
me tell you something I would almost bet
if we had the data which we can't get
our hands on but if I bet if we had the
data like Donald Trump was like our
freaking scare our hands on them
security tapes listen they got none
security tapes that he the important
part of that post was the security tapes
that I handed over right happily handed
over yeah okay okay great story Grandpa
listen listen I almost bet that there is
more drugs that walked in and out of the
Trump White House in four years then
probably this Administration and the
prior three administrations and I'm
talking about Obama Bush and Clinton
[__]
yeah way more way more and wait and
probably three times as much and I don't
care that's what a lot of people are
saying so I don't I don't give a [__] if
you don't believe me oh boy it's been a
hell of a show today I'm glad to be back
I'm glad to have you back you need to
get a [__] haircut I know I'll go get
a haircut today yeah okay good I'll
probably schedule something with Barbara
later you need to go get a [__]
haircut I'm excited to be back here I
hope tomorrow our YouTube comments work
so we can um
I know I don't know what the hell's
going on I need to check with stream
yard I'm gonna send him a message a
strongly worded message I want to speak
to the manager that's right I'm gonna go
all karen on their ass while I go Karen
on their ass why don't you subscribe to
YouTube that way we can see your
comments tomorrow hit the Subscribe
button it's free 99 it doesn't cost you
a single thing follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod wild it's still there
you can also go to the threads thing I
don't have a Graphic for it yet but you
can go the threads thing you can follow
me and Gabe at I am Gabe Sanchez at the
Tony Michaels same [__] handles if
you follow us on Instagram it's really
easy you just click that little badge
it's right bam underneath the photo you
click the bell I got a badge I gotta get
badge right I don't get a badge also
also download every single episode
today's episode will be on this
afternoon on Apple Spotify Google for
free and you know what while we're
speaking of the meta Universe while
we're on the meta Universe you might as
well go follow us on Facebook too you
can watch every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast there and follow
us on Twitch I want to go over to Twitch
here real quick oh we had a lot of
people re-sub s of using their Amazon
account don't forget to do that if
you've linked your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account make sure you're
re-subbing make sure you're
re-subscribing every single month to
give us the two dollars credit if you
don't resub every month we don't get the
two bucks I know it's a little bit of
work but here's what you do here's what
you do go go to the Tony michaels.com
let's see tonymichaels.com the
directions are like the fourth link down
you just click that it Mighty librarian
or great moderator on YouTube she gave
us she gave us proper instructions and I
linked to that there also you know it's
Thursday it feels like Monday because
it's the first day but it's Thursday so
tonight you're gonna vote for bone end
of the week I'm sure Gabe's going to
come up once he gets his haircut he's
going to come up with a great bonehead
poll yeah give me a minute
does threads have poles yet no not yet
but like I said like I said they have a
lot they have a lot of band [__] hey
hey can someone get Zuckerberg on the
phone I want I want polls over on
threads get him on the phone we'll get
him on the phone we'll make sure that
there's a thread um polls over on thread
soon I don't like the name threads I'm
gonna be honest with you well you know
maybe it's called threads because that
was a word that uh anyone couldn't
couldn't [__] ban that maybe maybe
that's maybe that's it maybe maybe he
did uh maybe he did give him a good
wallop uh with this threads thing so
they're probably better there are
probably better names that they could
have chosen but if they were comparing
words that would be filtered out by
by Elon you have to remember like what
is the most commonly used word it's
either the thread spool yeah
what you think they had huge meanings
about that particular like oh yeah for
sure and how can we yeah I mean I I can
only imagine that that
this has been something they've been
thinking about for a while right
and the timing lined up but they were
ready to go now whether they were like
oh [__] everything's hitting the fan we
gotta launch it right now in terms of
what happened with uh with Twitter and
Elon possibly
but I also look at this and said that
they were they've been considering this
wasn't like a [__] last minute
[__] up ditch effort and they just
threw [__] against the wall and like all
right well it works you know I think
what's happening is this has been
debated for and discussed for a while
and I also think that it was
you know their goal here is to bring
advertisers and Brands over in
celebrities and you know you just want
something that's like easy to go with
and also that and also and also you want
something that
kind of relates to what is it's being
used for I guess in that sense
right well and again I'm just saying I'm
not keen on the name threads it's not
the best name it sounds it sounds like a
clothing company to be quite honest with
you it doesn't really sound well I said
yesterday one of my first uh one of my
first posts on threads yesterday it said
uh
I said let the I was like let the games
begin but then my second post I think is
what I said is I said unhinged posts
equal loose threads right well that's
true so that's true well and I think
eventually it's just going to be
Instagram like they're gonna make the
two [__]
I I think it's going to be all one big
thing Instagram and threads is gonna end
up all one thing and it said you're just
gonna have one big it it it's that's
what I think but you know that's the
case that's totally fine I know what the
[__] as long as I don't have to see a
lot of crazy right-wing Nazis that's
true that's true well there'll be Nazis
on there they just won't be able to not
see as much over there everybody I'm
glad we're back I'm glad to have you
back
you got to be here today and visit with
us
um as I
come off a five-day hangover so same
time same place tomorrow it's Friday
bonan of the week don't miss it
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn head ass Beacon